Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, and
this past weekend, we raised $110,000 dollars for Crisis Text Line.
That is absolutely astonishing.
Thank you everybody so much for joining the charity livestream
and thank you everybody so much for donating to the cause.
If you don't know about Crisis Text Line, I'll leave a link
in the description below (the links to their website).
You can find out more about them, but I'm sure you know about it
because I blabbered endlessly about it.
AND it was fun!
It was so much fun to be there with my friends
and the whole gang was able to participate, and you guys were able to play with us.
And it was just a lot of fun, and I know we haven't been doing these charity livestreams
regularly enough, but I guarantee you this is the start of regular monthly charity livestreams.
In fact, Tyler and I are going back home to Cincinnati, and when we are there,
we are hoping to join Bob and Wade in a Cincinnati reunion charity livestream that
should be OODLES of fun.
We just have to set up a few things.
But that will be next month, and we're probably gonna do a Christmas theme to it.
And also, I wanna do a "12 Days of Christmas" video thing
that we're gonna be doing next month.
But that's getting a head of myself, because I wanted to talk about this week's videos.
And by the title of this video, which is probably something along the lines of
EMBRACE THE CRINGE!
Um. It was-- It was a lot of fun.
I-I'm not knocking what we did at all.
But it's just that thing about experimenting and trying new things.
And you definitely find the things that don't work!
And I mentioned this on the livestream
We went out to a park and we met with you guys
and it was a great experience, as it always is.
Uhm, but we tried something, which we probably shouldn't have tried
So-so basically, we out to the park, and it was super awesome
as it always is to meet you guys and be able to do videos with you guys
and there's still another video from that session that's gonna come out later.
But one of the things that we did do was attempt the don't laugh challenge in public.
And we discovered that, either that doesn't work in general
or we're just not funny, which I'm more inclined to believe the latter
of the two options there.
Because, something about being in public versus
a controlled environment like the office
is just vastly different because
the don't laugh challenge is supposed to be kinda cringey
because there's moments where it doesn't work, they don't laugh!
And it's just "HEY ok that joke didn't go anywhere gonna step away from the awkwardness now!"
You know, that's part of the experience but
when you're out in a park, you don't get to escape
You don't get to run away when something's bad
because, the weirdest thing was, there was an audience there!
You guys were there!
And you guys don't wanna be mean so
you kinda half laugh
but that's so much worse than just dead silence!
Because it's kinda funny, when a joke falls so flat on its face
that it's just crickets is all you can hear
And sometimes, like that is funny in and of itself
and that's what makes the don't laugh challenge good
but when you get a bad joke and then
"Heh...yeah" *sniffs* "Heheh"
That is the DEATH of comedy.
That is the death of everything.
And I talked about on the livestream that I was gonna play this and of course I am
Because I'm not gonna shy away from this one
It didn't work...and I'm gonna show you how-how not not workage it did
So this-this is what we're talking about
Mark in video:  Do that!
*laughing in the background*
Mark narrating: Oh. This is exactly what we're talking about when we say that
ya know...
Mark in video: There's a little leak!  Come on!
Mark narrating: The...
Mark in video: Do it!
Audience member: Don't do it!
*laughing in background*
*audience cheers*
Mark narrating: Yeah. I mean it'll work sometimes
because in the moment I guarantee you
everyone that was there was like "Yeah that was a good time!"
But then when you watch it back it's like
*anguished* "OHHH we were so desperately trying. Auhhh!"
Here we go.
Oh boy.
Ethan in video: Gotta go fast. Mark in video: Moo.
*audience chuckles*
Mark in video: Moo moo I'm a horse! Moo!
Moo!
Audience member: Oh that's spit!
Mark in video: Moo! It's not spit it's water! Moo!
Tyler in video: I got a big one coming out!
Mark in video: Moo! Ow! Ah! My knees!
Mark narrating: See the point is that in the moment
it could be funny but *laughing*
i-in NOT the moment, it-it's not!
*audience laughing in video*
Mark narrating: It's 100% not.
Ethan in video: HEY!
Audience members: What? *laughter*
Mark in video: Give me all your laughs!
I'll do it, I swear!
Give em to me! Laugh!
Laugh! Laugh!
What, no.
*audience chuckling*
Mark narrating: Ugh.
Mark in video: Woopeesh!
I'm a senator.
*audience laughs*
Mark in video: Wabam!
Oh, American family values are great!
Tyler in video: I'm Monica Lewinsky!
Audience member: Oh no!
Mark narrating: *anguished* EHHHHHH!
Ethan in video: Come on!
Tickle tickle!
*audience laughs sort of*
Mark in video: Four score and twenty years ago
you were still a bitch. *laughter*
Ethan in video: *old lady voice* Four score and twenty years ago, I could have a baby!
*silence, then laughter*
Mark narrating: *laughs*
*audience laughter*
*participant laughs*
Mark narrating: See, it works! It works but then it doesn't work.
But it was still fun! I'm not- I'm not gonna say this wasn't fun
It's one of those moments
life if you ever see that video
if you ever see that video where uh..
the world's worst like..uh..
the world's worst flash mob
It's where they do Gangam Style in the mall
Uh... what am I talking about I'll just pull it up.
It's-it's-it's this video
Hang on... wait...
It-it-it's this video where they're in the mall
and you see em like.. *laughs*
It's...they just think
Oh my god
It's just, they're not committing and that's the problem
They're like..It's like half committing.
It's the essence of all.. and then this guy waiting in the wings
Like.. there's so many people that are waiting in the wings
And then there's no coordination
and-and that's exactly what we had going on here.
But they probably had fun!
They probably had a lot of fun.
And then everyone watching was like "Aw, that's cute."
But then as soon as it get's put on the internet, it's unedited and
it's just a non stop barrage of awkward.
It gets pretty bad! *laughs*
And that's kind of what happened here.
And it's not any fault of you guys.
It's only us *laughs* it's only us!
Oh wait. I wanna talk about this guy
That guy right here.
*laughs*
Tha-that kid..really...that kid was really funny!
Not for good reasons! But he was just funny!
Kid in video: What do a call a squirrel that flies? A flying squirrel.
*audience laughs*
Mark narrating: *laughs*
I just gotta say..
Kid in video: What do you call a person...
Audience: 8...
7...
6...
5...
4...
3...
2...
1...
0!
Mark narrating: This just...oh my god...
Audience member: Yaaay.
Mark narrating: It was just the
It's the world's saddest countdown
Then it's just... it's the funniest shit *laughing*
It's literally  just the world's saddest countdown!
Mark narrating deep and sadly and audience: 9..
Audience: 0
Mark narrating: *laughter*
It's just that they're.. the-the somber "yaaaay" *turns to laughter*
I-I hate to say that it's bad because
It was-it was the kids like.. dead pan jokes that almost actually made me laugh
Cause he said-he said
What the first one was like
*deadpan* "What do you call a squirrel that flies? A flying squirrel."
And it was just the way that he delivered it! *giggles*
It was just really funny to me!
And then the next one was
*deadpan* "What do you call a guy in the ground? A dead guy"
*laughs* It's just like.. OH my god.
They aren't BAD jokes, they're anti jokes.
And those are funny, where as bad jokes are not.
And it's just, there's a distinct difference.
It's like that Brian Regan joke where he said..or his son said..
"Ho-how come how come dinosaurs..can't talk?"
"Well, I dunno know."
"Cause they're all dead."
Also I want to mention that Ethan spit on my face.
Right here.
If you watch, here comes the sad, sad countdown.
Audience: 4..
Mark in video: I know there are drugs in here somewhere!
3..
Mark in video: Where are the fucking drugs?!
2..
1..
Mark in video: Don't spit on me! You spit on me!!
Audience: *loud cheers*
Mark narrating: Spitting right now my face!
Right after the saaaad countdown!
It was a good end to the video, it really was!
But uh, man it was just silly.
Anyway, I uh.. I *laughs*
I don't have enough time to show you the entire video
But, trust me! The rest is just exactly as that!
But anyway, I just like.. i-it's still fun!
I don't want to knock this in anyway
It's not not fun to go out here and do this stuff with you guys
But there's just a-a line to cross in terms of making a video out of it
and putting it up on the internet
Because Kathyrn was trying to edit that one
and then Kathyrn was just like going up to me and was like
"It's not funny..it's not funny!"
And I go like "Oh it can't be THAT bad!"
*gasps*
"Oh my god...I'm not funny" *laughs*
And then like.. we couldn't e- we couldn't even hide behind the shield of awkwardness
to try to make it a good video.
Cause-cause we could not put that up and go
"Here ya go everybody! This is funny, right?"
*forced fake laughter*
So the only way we can talk about it is in the sense that
"We know it was not good!"
So anyway
That is uh.. that is the story of that.
But oddly enough! That's the way that uh, Ethan
was telling me about the other video
Uh, the one that we did put up, the Don't Laugh Challenge that we did.
Because Ethan told me, "This video's not funny either.."
And then we all gathered around and watched it
And we could not catch out breaths
Because we were laughing so hard
It was so incredibly funny to us.
Because it was the perfect blend of awkward cringeyness
with ACTUAL funnyness
Just the spontaneity and the improvisation of it
makes for a really fun video.
And that's why I love those types of videos.
But that does not mean that I won't be doing Try Not to Laugh Challenge
which is gonna come again very soon.
I've got a stock pile of videos, I just gotta go through em again.
Maybe I'll just to incorporate a "You Guys" component to that too
but I don't know! There's a lot of holiday stuff coming up
but we do aim to get out there with you guys a lot more.
So! That is the wrap up for this week.
We've had just a ton of fun.
An-and I'm super happy with the way things have been going
because I've been more motivated than ever
to just get videos done
An-I-I'm hon- I'm like honored that I've got so many cool people around me that
wanna push me to be better and
and uh make better videos
and just get out there and do stuff everyday
and try new things.
I don't regret trying this new thing!
I don't regret trying.
Even if it turns out to be bad.
I do not regret trying.
And that's something that I would encourage you guys
to go out and do.
Because, in this regard, we failed.
But fear of failure shouldn't be something that dissuades you from trying new things
and going out there and expanding your horizons.
Because you never know what's actually going to work
until you go out there and do it.
And I guarantee there's some people that are funnier than we are
that could've made that work.
Just...not us.
And not then.
So either way
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Look forward to another charity livestream next month
with even more friends
it should be super awesome and hopefully back in Cincinnati.
AND look forward to Bob and Wade coming out here to visit very soon.
So, thank you again everybody for watching!
And as always, I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh Bye!